something strange is happening on the
outskirts of our solar system
it could be a large mysterious planet
or it could be
a black hole
how big would this black hole be
what effect would it have on our solar
system
and what would happen to you if you got
too close
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a black hole was already in
our solar system
far beyond neptune there are small icy
objects orbiting our sun
these are trans-neptunian objects or
tnos
and these tnos have an oddly clustered
orbit pattern
and this type of orbit
doesn't happen on its own
something is making those objects orbit
like that
and
whatever that something is
it would need to be at least 17 times
more massive than the earth
and 10 times further from the sun than
neptune is
could it be the mysterious planet nine
well so far there's no evidence to back
up the theory of a massive ninth planet
disrupting the orbits of these objects
but scientists have another possible
explanation
one that could spell trouble for
humanity
what if planet nine
isn't a planet at all but a planet-sized
black hole
if you try to picture a planet-sized
black hole
you might imagine a massive void that is
devouring everything in its path
but a black hole of this size would be
small
that's because this black hole would be
the mass of a planet yeah and all that
mass would be packed into an extremely
dense amount of space
no bigger than a grapefruit
well you've seen enough what if at this
point to know that black holes come in
bigger sizes too
stellar black holes get 10 to 24 times
the mass of our sun and they're pretty
common astronomers estimate there may be
anywhere from 10 million to 1 billion in
the milky way galaxy alone if our own
sun transformed into a black hole
it would only be about 5.8 kilometers
wide
this scenario could cause one or two
significant problems for life on earth
but let's get back to our tiny black
hole hiding at the edge of the solar
system
it might be small but it would have
enough mass to disrupt the orbits of the
trans-neptunian objects
but with a black hole that far away from
earth and in a fixed orbit around the
sun
you wouldn't see much of a difference in
your day today
but where's the fun in that so in the
best traditions of our mind-blowing
scenarios let's destabilize the black
hole's orbit
just a little
the extreme nature of black holes
manifests itself only when an object is
close to the event horizon
this is the threshold around a black
hole where an object would need to
travel faster than the speed of light to
escape the gravitational pull
you might know it as the point of no
return
well for this particular black hole to
become dangerous for earth
its gravitational pull would need to be
much stronger
this tiny black hole would need to be
able to pull in entire planets
combine the great pole with a bit of a
disrupted orbit and you've got an
invisible gravitational monster
swallowing our planetary neighbors one
by one
as the planets and asteroids from our
solar system reached the event horizon
they would be torn apart into small
subatomic components and compressed to a
single point
from earth we'd see neptune
uranus saturn and jupiter disappear into
nothingness
then
mars would be gone too
earth would be next
as the black hole approached earth would
begin to bulge
this would cause massive earthquakes
volcanic eruptions and tsunamis all over
the planet
if you somehow survived up to this point
the end would be near
as our planet got closer to the black
hole it and everything on it would be
pulled apart and stretched out
this is a process known as
spaghettification
chances are you die long before you
could get anywhere close to the event
horizon and eventually
the earth would be sucked into this tiny
gravitational monster until there was
nothing left
well maybe a trail of debris would serve
as a reminder that earth had existed at
all
but this wouldn't happen in an instant
in 2013 scientists observed a planet
about 14 to 30 times as massive as
jupiter being swallowed by a black hole
and the whole process from initial
disturbance to total destruction
took two to three months
now when it comes to this distant object
its stable orbit of the sun for billions
of years is a good sign that there isn't
much cause for concern
but when we start to see changes in
other planets moons and asteroids then
something dangerous might be going on
and maybe planet nine is just another
planet in the solar system
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]